place à présent à notre focus du jour et
direction la turquie l'une des
principales terre d'accueil pour les
réfugiés pour la plupart des syriens des
hommes des femmes des enfants ont été
longtemps accueilli en tant qu'invité et
soigner gratuitement par l'état turc
mais dix ans après le début du conflit
le ton vous allez voir a quelque peu
changé les appels à renvoyer ces
populations dans leur pays se
multiplient notamment a beau lui cette
ville moyenne d'un atelier tenu par un
maire nationaliste
c'est ce qu'ont pu constater nos
correspondants cet art portage de
ludovic de foucauld shauna bhattacharya
hussein assad
c'est une ville au nord d'ankara connu
pour avoir hébergé le héros barre de
légendaires que l'on nous sorte de robin
des bois du mont turcs mais c'est pour
une tout autre raison que blue fait
l'actualité en turquie la ville est
devenue le symbole du vent de
discrimination anti arabe qui souffle
sur le pays
à chaque fois que quelque chose se passe
en syrie on sait qu'il y aura des
problèmes ici seïf est originaire d'irak
il est arrivé à baulou il ya sept ans il
préfère rester anonyme
ici ils ne font pas de différence que tu
sois syriens ou irakiens c'est pareil
les quelques mois des soldats turcs ont
été tués en syrie alors ils s'en sont
pris à tous les arabes il nous disait
rentrez chez vous rentrez et battez vous
pourquoi ça nous de mourir dans votre
pays mais en quoi c'est ma photo
nettement selon seïf a fui la guerre il
dit aujourd'hui avoir à affronter une
autre sorte de violence
la guerre psychologique c'est encore
pire que la vraie guerre quand on
travaille nous regardent comme si on
était des privilégiés des gens très
riches comme si on leur voler leur
boulot il nous reproche tout c'est une
guerre plus dur que si elle était menée
avec de vraies armes
la mairie comme la province sont tenus
par le ch et le parti kémaliste la plus
grande organisation politique de
l'opposition turque d'après des mesures
locales actuellement en suspens car très
controversé les étrangers devaient
s'acquitter de factures d'eau et
d'énergie majorer le coût d'un mariage à
l'hôtel de ville devaient leur revenir
sans voix plus cher que pour les turcs
enfin un couvre-feu devait leur être
imposées après 21h
nous avons tenté de joindre le maire
josiane son équipe nous a indiqué qu'il
ne souhaitait pas s'exprimer dans la
presse étrangère le voici sur un plateau
d'une télévision turque
70% des étrangers a beau lui sont
irakiens y at il une guerre en irak nos
hommes d'affaires apporte des emplois et
des capitaux en irak à bagdad et à erbil
ce système qui a permis de les inviter à
fait son temps on doit faire en sorte
qu'ils repartent parce que les chiffres
augmentent
comment voulez vous intégrer un afghan
les afghans harcèle le jeune fille de 15
ans et ils ne s'en rendent même pas
compte parce que dans leur pays ils se
marient à des fillettes de 9 ans comment
voulez vous intégrer ces gens
la turquie accueille plus de réfugiés
que n'importe quel autre pays dans le
monde 3 millions 700 mille syrien 330000
irakien des hommes des femmes des
enfants qui ne peuvent pas être renvoyés
dans leur pays d'origine même s'ils ne
sont techniquement pas considérés comme
réfugiés par la loi turque ils ont un
statut d'invité vos particularités
juridiques qui ne semble plus adapté
il n'y a pas de vraie politique
devrait plan d'intégration en turquie
le problème
et il n'y a pas de transparence sur la
politique migratoire
ou la sonatel spécialiste de politique
migratoire à l'université d'istanbul
selon elle les réfugiés étaient d'abord
bienvenus les actes xénophobes sont
apparus quand les turcs ont compris que
les immigrés étaient là pour rester
la feuillée if you pour régler la
question des réfugiés il faut commencer
par leur offrir une protection
des populations réfugiées devrait
devenir des membres de la société
car il n'ya pas d'opportunité ils ne
peuvent pas rentrer il ya toujours des
conflits en cours
mais aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
tout ça ne fonctionne plus
la dégradation de la situation
économique noircit encore le tableau les
étrangers sont accusés d'être
responsables de la hausse des prix de
l'immobilier de faire baisser les
salaires voire de prendre les emplois
les turcs mais ce qui inquiète encore
plus ce forum qui réunit des groupes de
défense des droits des réfugiés c'est la
banalisation de la xénophobie dans la
parole publique qui est égale à celle de
taele gazier est un syrien qui travaille
pour le ministère tueur de l'éducation
est aussi activistes il rencontre des
dirigeants politiques turcs pour tenter
de les convaincre de ne pas profiter du
climat actuel pour des raisons
électoralistes lors de la mise à double
moi
c'est assez lourd qui est
en fait toutes les factions leur part de
responsabilité le gouvernement comme
l'opposition c'est la responsabilité de
tous de mettre un terme au discours de
haine car ces discours ne menace pas
seulement la communauté syrienne mais
aussi la communauté turque dans son
ensemble
le 2 août dernier des centaines de
personnes s'en sont pris à des commerces
et des logements dans cette banlieue
d'ankara après que deux syriens ont été
accusés d'avoir causé la mort d'un
adolescent turc l'état turc y confronter
un paradoxe continue de recevoir de
l'argent de l'union européenne pour
garder les migrants sur son territoire
mais une partie de plus en plus
importante de la population ne veut plus
les accueillir